son statut de chef de la puissante
église orthodoxe russe lui a toujours
conféré une place centrale dans la
société le Patriarche de Moscou Kiril et
le chef spirituel de 150 millions de
fidèles à travers le monde mais il est
aussi devenu avec la guerre en Ukraine
le bras armé du nationalisme de Vladimir
Poutine une collusion forte et de très
longue date qui se matérialise lors des
sermons du patriarche comme celui-ci
trois jours après l'invasion russe de
l'Ukraine
dieu interdit que la situation politique
actuelle dans l'Ukraine fraternel et
pour but de faire prévaloir les forces
du mal qui ont toujours combattu l'unité
de la Russie et de l'Église russe
c'est en 2009 que keryl de son vrai nom
Vladimir goundyev est nommé 16e
Patriarche de Moscou et de toutes les
Russie comme Poutine Kerry l'a connu une
irrésistible à son ordonnez-moi d'un 23
ans il fait ses armes au service de la
diplomatie religieuse et en tant
qu'espion au sein du KGB entre les
années 70 et 90 il gravit les échelons
de l'Église orthodoxe jusqu'à devenir
archevêque et métropolite c'est durant
cette période qu'il va faire fortune
dans l'industrie du tabac grâce au
licence accordée par l'État à l'Église
orthodoxe russe Kiril s'aligne sur les
positions de Poutine il dépeint lui
aussi un Occident moralement décadant et
hadoube tous les projets militaires du
Kremlin à de nombreuses reprises il
bénit les chats russes qui partent pour
l'Ukraine si une personne meurt en
accomplissant son devoir alors c'est
incontestablement une bonne action
équivalente à un sacrifice
ces prises de position ON précipité la
scission entre les Églises orthodoxes
ukrainiennes et russes en 2018 le pape
François que Kyril a rencontré en 2016
laquée d'enfants de cœur de Poutine